[Music]
[Music]
not on my watch [ __ ]
oh
give me a [ __ ] wallet
[Music]
[Music]
no okay no just tell him wade called
thank you
wow nice suit zip it stanley
[Music]
oh jesus oh
that's not good no no no oh you're not
going to walk that one off
oh that's so gross ah
i'm so sorry you know i i spent way too
long in the phone booth
if i'm being honest with myself i
probably should have just called 9-1-1
well none of that matters now
because i think we're both missing the
real point here
ah the [ __ ] is a phone booth
doing on a street corner those disappear
in 98
i suppose i could have just used my cell
and jerry garcia ice cream you gonna eat
this
don't answer now just rest
i mean actually i made a call to the
costumer his name is laird he usually
helps me put the suit on
i don't know how the other guys do it so
quickly he probably wouldn't be dead if
it was logan
because he got to change into where's a
[ __ ] tank top and a pair of jeans
yeah like to get my tank top on
bit of perspiration have a nice little
crime fighting spree yeah
happy hugger call a day
i guess we're both doing guns now i just
didn't know that
well that's intense